brought to you by the PlayStation
experience in Las Vegas take part in all
the announcements panels and early game
previews December sixth and seventh it's
that time again to talk to you about the
latest games in new releases and this
week you don a backpack a headlamp and a
stylish ascot and embark on an exciting
journey seeking shiny gold stars with
captain toad treasure tracker toad may
not be able to jump but he makes up for
being vertically challenged with his
quick wit and blind ambition he's like
the Rudy of Nintendo this colorful and
whimsical world marks the first time
that toad will get his very own game and
it looks super fun your fun-filled wii u
adventure begins on the 5th wii u isn't
done yet because it knows the quickest
way to your heart is to get you right in
the childhood nes remix pack is a
physical copy of both nes remix and nes
remix 2 which contains Donkey Kong
excitebike golf ice climber Mario Bros
pinball super mario bros tennis The
Legend of Zelda dr. Mario ice hockey kid
icarus Kirby's Adventure Metroid NES
open tournament golf Super Mario Bros 1
through 3 and more if any of those bring
back fond memories consider grabbing
this off the shelf on the 5th nes remix
will also be coming to 3ds the same day
speaking of nostalgia remember chivalry
medieval warfare on PC and all the
insane multiplayer action well it's on
xbox 360 and ps3 this week so you can
relive all the dismemberment all the
silly commands and that time you found
the low gravity server
start decapitating December third while
we're at it let's mention kingdom hearts
HD 2.5 remix arriving on ps3 this week
giving you three fantastical journeys in
one complete HD remastered collection
you get an upgrade from four by three to
sixteen by nine as well as upgraded
textures character details like Riku and
new remixed audio get your Keyblade out
December second lastly take a long drive
across the country with your buds
picking which Coast actually has the
most in this stunning open world
environment the single-player campaign
puts you in the driver's seat as Alex
Taylor voiced by none other than the
great and dreamy Troy Baker that guy's
in everything shift into high gear on
the second for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week